[Music]
sterling is composed of ninety two point
five percent silver and 7.5 percent
alloy the alloy is usually copper or
copper combined with other metals this
manufacturer pours the standard ratio of
alloy and pure silver into a stainless
steel mold the silver rapidly cools and
hardens into a flat bar workers send the
bar between two rollers which apply over
3,300 pounds of pressure workers feed
the bar through the press repeatedly
each time turning the wheel to narrow
the gap between the rollers to
progressively thin out the silver bar
rolling the silver bar makes it riddle
so they reheat it to restore its
flexibility and malleability the bar now
goes through another rolling press
reducing the thickness even more
[Music]
in doing so it lengthens the silver bar
dramatically from 10 inches to 4 yards
the strip now passes through a series of
forming rollers which progressively
curls the edges up and inward until the
strut becomes a hollow tube then the
Machine solder the edges sealing the
tube the tube is still too thick for
making earrings and rings so it goes to
another thinning operation this machine
grabs one end of the tube and pulls it
through a series of circular dies which
have progressively narrower diameters
once the tube is the required diameter a
winding machine curves it to make hoop
earrings an artisan steadies a piece of
curved tube and locking tweezers he
sutter's on an earring hook then a latch
into which the hook snaps some pieces of
jewelry incorporate cubic zirconia
stones in this design a computer has
already cut to pattern pieces out of an
ultra-thin silver sheet and rounded the
sheets into half spheres the artisan
solder is the two halves together
encasing the cubic zirconia stones
inside the rest of the earring
components are made from silver tubing
and silver wire here an artisan is
making a pendant he locks cubic zirconia
stones in between the front and back
frame pieces then he positions the
center piece within the frame soldering
it in four spots he satyrs a ring to the
top of the pendant and the loop for the
chain called the bail next a rotating
barrel of abrasive powder rounds the
edges and smooth rough spots a buffing
with a cloth wheel then polishes the
silver to a mirror finish the same
computerized laser machine that cut the
sphere earrings can also act an
elaborate design on the surface of the
piece it can reproduce virtually any
image that can be created with software
the laser draws by pulverizing a micro
layer of silver as the laser works a
built-in suction device vacuums the
silver powder away besides adding
strength and durability the alloy makes
sterling silver shinier the copper in
particular has anti corrosive properties
which resists tarnishing